what is the number one issue facing
women today
not being raised in a two-parent
household
I've had the issues
um safety not being able to walk
at night by myself I'm terrified I'm not
being trained to be a woman or a lady or
mother I have a question about that
night um do you think men can walk home
alone at night no no nice Peak for them
as well yeah I mean there's an age
bracket the way that London is right now
yeah no definitely not
um but I feel like there's just more
risk when you're a woman I mean
so if I get attacked and a man gets
attacked who's more likely to get help
from other men the women the woman yeah
because someone might come across and
not even know who to help if it's two
men but with the woman like I feel like
people will automatically yeah have you
seen those videos of the woman hitting
the man and the Man hitting the wall
yeah and it's like they always help the
woman the man they're like good luck
yeah
yeah I don't know personally I just
don't feel safe on the streets
um I get Ubers literally everywhere or
you know someone will pick me up or
I'm terrified to walk alone by myself
just even coming here to tonight I was
terrified
is that cool because you get like
hollowed out on the roads and uh hi
darling no not even that I can handle
that but I've actually been followed
home like I've been followed home like
you know I've had someone trying to rob
me I've had someone try and touch me
inappropriately you know and it's it's a
lot to deal with and what area is that
sorry to see
um well I'm from east London so wow yeah
just okay I don't know
um anyone else number one issue facing
women
I don't know if it's number one but I do
want to bring it up again I think
promiscuity
is um
tainting us especially like now like you
know you're a similar age to me like
we've been on social media I don't know
about you but like I think I got
Snapchat when I was like 13. yeah so
it's like I know like before you had
like page three and things like that but
like
I just feel like things have changed and
like now you'll see like 10 year old
kids who are like like they'll just see
these like only fans models or whatever
like and it's just so like they don't
even blink like it's just so like
everyone's just used to it and Tick Tock
as well even like Tick Tock you have
like 14 year olds looking like they're
18 like you know moving their waist
around it's like like it's really scary
I've seen it it's really scary and I
just don't think it's gonna do anyone
any help in the long run men or women
like it's it's tainting everyone's view
of everything in my opinion 100 the
number one thing for women right now is
body image yeah yeah definitely body
image whoever is
having your waist your bombing your tits
your lips Botox is definitely body image
weave or whatever like yeah I feel it
for you women because like if you don't
look a certain way you're not doing it
you know what I'm saying women were
worried about body image then why are 60
of women overweight in the UK it's worse
it's worse in America it's like 80
percent
but don't you think I feel like
sometimes
um like even if you're overeating even
if you feel like you want to look a type
of way
so even if you feel like you want to
look a type of way like you might just
eat it away yeah gain weight then you
gain weight by eating lunch I guess but
people are emotional eaters
that's true yeah but also I feel like a
lot of women get into relationships or
they get very comfortable and they just
start to put on weight like just
naturally I don't know yeah facts yeah
comfortable yeah and I don't know they
call it like relationship weight
um but then you just take it too far and
then you really let yourself go but
you're like I've got to get in the gym
but my point is I always hear women say
that like they care so much about beauty
standards but it's like if you cared
about beauty standards then why aren't
you 120 pounds I would say another
problem would be a lot of females are
emotionally unstable that'll be another
issue
to put all of that in a box yeah but
some people when they say they care
about their body image they're not
actually talking about their weight they
might just be talking about here how
their lips look how their eyes look how
so they're not focusing on their body
just think about this bit who has worse
beauty standards men are women
would you be like looking for or yeah
who is who is harder beauty standards to
meet men or women oh women women women
how so when women only swipe right five
percent of the time on dating apps and
they also find 80 of men is unattractive
I think men have it harder because the
chances of a man an individual Man
versus an individual woman of being
found attractive by the majority is a
lot lover for a man so like maybe like
they see the maybe like women we see you
know someone on I don't know like a
magazine or something we think oh I
don't look like her like sure that's a a
body standard that we feel like we have
to live up to but that's just how we
feel that's not the reality the reality
is we don't have to live live up to
anything really the majority of like
girls can find someone to partner up
with them sleep with them whatever it
may be whereas guys sure there might not
be a very obvious in your face you must
look like this but us girls as the judge
of men
um they've got way more to live up to
like the average guy like most of us
probably wouldn't mind I don't really
agree with that I feel like imagine if
only two women in this room were found
attractive by Men by the majority of men
that'd be sad
two face so how how can you say we have
worse beauty standards
like it's not it's not that it's not
even girls saying they're okay like they
deem 80 of men as unattractive not just
oh he's okay he's kind of he's medium
ugly
I don't think looks are looked at that
much when it comes to men I'll be honest
with you I think women look at status
they look at financial status they look
at where is this man at in his life also
yeah I mean obviously you have to be
attracted to the person that you're
dating but most of the time
personally me and like people that I
know the women in my life they have
never really looked at a guy and gone oh
he's got a really pretty face they're
like he's a man he's a man he's tall
yeah he's gonna be taller than you at
least a woman I've dated men who were
shorter than women and I'm a tall woman
yeah but you're not you're not the
majority and we're talking about women
in general women filter out men under
six foot on dating apps eighty percent
of the time
and the saddest thing is normally like
five foot five and they're taking all
the two men yeah six foot two babies
yeah but people's motives people's
motives on dating apps are also very
questionable and women most of women do
go on there as well and just to get a
bit of an ego boost or have a free meal
whatever like and I I think that would
be true if that's not the number one way
that people were meeting today
um so you know if the outcomes weren't
relationships that's the number one way
then I would agree with you but
I don't know I just don't think that
there that we really like look too deep
into men's appearance that much yes we
like Kai I think we do look at the
height but I don't think we look at oh
is his face perfect oh he's got a double
chin you know women look at stuff like
that we look at things oh my face looks
fat like oh I need to get a nose job we
look at it not men
so it's like it's like how are we gonna
like men don't care yeah but it's this
ideology that men like that typical like
Barbie skinny small waist petite girl
and I guess Society has kind of told us
that and we've sort of believed it and
the media also tell us that as well so
over the years we've just kind of we've
been brainwashed we we think that that's
what we love doing let's not listen to
the Our Song in high school
yeah I feel like the skinny trend is
coming in now look at the Kardashians
look at Kylie Jenner she just got rid of
her BBL you know Kim's gone super skinny
yeah but none of them are wives yeah
like yeah they make money but they're
not wives that's true it's not it's like
women are changing for women they're not
even doing it for men if you ask men
what they want they don't want lip
filler they don't want your forehead not
to move they don't want to pound a
makeup they just want like natural light
okay can I ask you can I can I ask you a
question okay I hear hear what you're
saying but answer me this if they don't
want the girls with the lip fillers and
the big balms and the skinny little
waist why is it when you go down a guy
is following on Instagram every single
girl he is following looks like that oh
do men look at Instagram for wives candy
no why candy
no it's no good for them they all want a
piece of it it's like if you look at
their corn Star Search is it is it going
to be the wife material okay they don't
want to imagine that but if they're
looking at people if they're looking at
women like that then they
somewhat find those women attractive no
yeah for the night yeah Candy's like
sweets I always say it's like sweets
because it is like you know it's no good
for you but you just want to really but
isn't that scary for when you get into a
relationship and you think oh he's going
to cheat them if he just wants a piece
of it and it's that good it depends what
kind of man you're going I don't know
people are so fussy about picking him
man just have a lower attraction floor
than us yeah so it's kind of like for
I've had guys explain this where they're
like if you're just above their like
minimum dating floor it's kind of all
the same to them I mean obviously
there's some girl like the hotter you
are the more you get away with in a way
that's what they say they're kind of
like the Richer they are for a lot of
women the more they get away with in a
way but no matter not nearly as picky
they're kind of like enough there's two
girls are more we're more judgmental to
ourselves than how men are judgmental to
us
oh yeah